Sleep Number store.
AND THE LESSONS TO ARE LEARNED.
THAT'S TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
A LOT OF FINGER POINTING TODAY.
BLAMING THE PRESIDENT AND
CONSERVATIVE AND BLAMING STEVE
BANNON OR MITCH McCONNELL FOR
THE FALL OF ROY MOORE.
THE TRUTH IS THE RACE HAD ZERO
ALLEGATIONS IN A FLAWED
CANDIDATE.
REMEMBER THE ISSUES THAT TRUMP
WON ON.
AT TIME NO TIME WHEN I PEEKED IN
TRADE, IMMIGRATION, NONE OF
THOSE THINGS WERE DEBATEED IN
THE BM RACE.
A MAN THAT MANY BELIEVED COULD
RUN AGAINST DOUG JONES IN 2020
THERE WAS NO SUBSTANCE TO THIS.
THERE WAS NO DISCUSSION OF
TRUMP'S POLICIES OR ROY MOORE'S
POLICIES.
THEY MADE SURE DOUG JONES'S
POLICIES WERE NOT DISCUSSED.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT SCANDAL.
>> Laura: IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST MOORE.
THE VOLATILE NATURE OF THIS
SPECIAL ELECTION IN ALABAMA WAS
A JOKE.
MITCH McCONNELL AND HIS PACK
RUSHED IN AND PROTECTED OR TRIED
TO PROTECT STRANGE RATHER THAN
JUST LET THE PEOPLE DUKE IT OUT
AND SORT IT OUT.
PROBABLY A BETTER PATH.
CONSULTANTS FOR CONGRESSMAN MO
BROOKS WERE WARNED THEY SHOULD
NOT WORK AGAINST LUTHER STRANGE.
REPORTS WERE THEY WERE
THREATENED.
THEN THE PRESIDENT PUT HIS RIGHT
LEG IN FOR STRANGE AND THEN TOOK
IT OUT AND PUT IN FOR MOORE.
THAT HE LOST BECAUSE OF TRUMP IS
RIDICULOUS.
ALABAMA IS TRUMP COUNTRY.
PEOPLE LOVE THRUM IN ALABAMA.
THE VOTERS ARE SOME OF THE MOST
IMMIGRATION ISSUES AND SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE ROY MOORE.
HE LOST THE GOVERNOR'SERACY
TWICE.
AS MATT TWEETED LAST NIGHT.
JUST TOO MUCH CRAZY IN NERVE
RACKING TIMES.
THERE IS A LIMIT.
THE PEN BALL MACHINE HIT TILT
AND ALABAMA JUST WANTED IT OVER.
THINKING BACK ON THE ELECTION.
YOU LOOK AT ROY MOORE AND TRUMP
AND THEIR APPROACH.
THEY ARE NOT SIMILAR.
TRUMP WAS ABOUT MAKING AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
ROY MOORE WAS ABOUT MAKING
ALABAMA GRIMACE AGAIN.
A LESSON FOR REPUBLICANS.
YOU CAN'T FIGHT EVERYONE AT
ONCE.
INDUSTRY AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF YOUR PARTY UNLESS YOUR
THAT DEMANDS CANDIDATES WHO ARE
FEARLESS AND UNAFRAID TO DO
INTRODUCE.
-- INTRODUCE.
INTERVIEWS.
THE OTHER TAKEAWAY IS THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR REPUBLICANS TO
ENGAGE MINORITY VOTERS.
ESPECIALLY IN PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
HOSTILE TO THE BRAND OF THE GOP.
IN ALABAMA 30% OF THE ELECTORATE
FOR BLACK VOTERS.
THE GOP NEEDS TO REACH OUT TO
THIS COMMUNITY.
KEEP DOING THOSE CAMPAIGN STYLE
EVENTS.
WHEN TRUMP WENT TO THE BLACK
THEY MAY NOT HAVE LIKED HIM BUT
YOU TALK TO VOTERS AND THEY
RESPECT YOU MORE.
THEY KNOW YOU CARED JUST TO SHOW
UP TO HEAR THEIR CONCERNS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO DO THIS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED A BLACK
PASTOR TO TALK ABOUT HIS TAX
PLAN AND WHAT CAN IT DO FOR THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
THIS WAS GOOD.
>> WE REPRESENT A COUNTRY OF
MANY AFRICAN-AMERICAN FAMILIES.
FAMILIES NEED THIS NOW.
IT'S TIME FOR A CHANGE.
IT'S TIME THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR PRESIDENT IS MAKING GOOD ON
HIS PROMISES!
>> Laura: YOU DIDN'T SEE THAT IN
THE EVENING NEWS.
PREACHING LAW AND ORDER TO THE
THEY WANT A MONOPOLY ON THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE.
THEY HAD IT FOR A LONG TIME.
THIS IS WHAT IS NEEDED.
ALABAMA REINFORCES THAT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT GETS IT.
LET'S HOPE THE ALABAMA RACE
SERVE AS A WAKE UP CALL TO THE